[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
today's topic is the languages of italy
as you probably know
italy is located in europe on the
mediterranean sea
and shares borders with france
switzerland austria slovenia
and san marino why not call this video
the italian language
that's because italian as we normally
think of it is not the only language of
italy
in italy there have historically been
many different local varieties of speech
that developed from vulgar latin these
dialects differ significantly from one
locale to another
but they can be grouped together with
other similar dialects
and those groups of dialects can be
considered regional languages
one of these groups of dialects is
tuscan or toscano
which forms the basis of standard
italian to be precise
the tuscan dialect of florence spoken in
the 15th to 16th centuries
formed the basis of standard italian the
modern tuscan dialects which vary from
place to place are spoken by around 3.5
million people mainly in tuscany
part of umbria and a couple of locales
on the islands of sardinia and corsica
standard italian on the other hand is
spoken by most of italy's 60 million
people
it's now learned universally by italians
because it's the language of education
and the media
and in many areas especially urban areas
it has largely replaced the traditional
regional languages
in most of the country say from around
rome to the north
the regional languages are used mostly
amongst the elderly
and in more casual speech especially
outside of the larger cities
in the south of the country specifically
in campagna calabria and sicily
as well as sardinia regional languages
are more widely spoken
but the trend is that the regional
languages are fading for the most part
why when italy became a nation in 1861
the policy was to italianize people in
all the different regions of the new
country
this was done by making italian the sole
language of education
and of media and of government also
internal migration of people seeking new
industrial
jobs brought the speakers of different
regional languages together
forcing them to speak standard italian
in order to communicate
in such regions notably in the north the
regional languages have faded more
quickly
data from the italian national institute
of statistics
shows that around half of italians speak
mainly italian with their families and
friends
and this number rises to 72.8 percent
when speaking to strangers
about 33 percent of people speak both
italian and their dialect with family
and friends
and 19 with strangers 16 speak
only their dialect with their families
13.2 percent speak only in dialect with
their friends
and 5.4 percent with strangers notice
that i wrote the word dialect with
quotation marks
we have to be careful with that word
dialect because it might suggest that
these regional languages are varieties
of standard italian or varieties of
tuscan but they are not varieties of
italian or tuscan from which italian
derived they developed in parallel with
tuscan
their dialects in the sense that there
are many different local varieties of
speech but they are not dialects of one
single language
these dialects are often quite different
from each other and they are grouped
together based on their historical
development
their common features and their mutual
intelligibility and can be thought of as
languages
but most of these languages are not
standardized and exactly how to group
the dialects together is not always
clear
as standard italians spread and began to
replace the traditional regional
languages
some features of those traditional
languages made their way into standard
italian in each area
this resulted in different dialects of
standard italian mostly different
accents
and also some casual vocabulary adopted
from those regional languages
some of italy's language groups are
recognized as historic language
minorities
such as albanian german greek slovene
croatian french franco provencal
friulian
ladin occitan catalan and sardinian
some of these are not romance languages
and some of them are national languages
or regional languages in other nearby
countries
it's also worth noting that the
languages on this list that are specific
to italy
all have standard written forms which
may be part of the reason they are
recognized as minority languages
and not mere dialects other such
languages with standard written forms
are
piedmontese ligurian and venetian the
regional language with the largest
number of speakers is neapolitan
or nabulintana it is spoken by around
5.7 million people
primarily in baso lazio abruzzo and
molise
puglia basilicata and parts of calabria
like standard italian and tuscan it is
part of the italo-dalmatian branch of
the romance languages
and it has some degree of
intelligibility for speakers of italian
but it's also influenced by spanish
french and arabic this is not one of the
recognized minority languages
and is often considered a dialect in
italy though it's very reasonable to
consider it a separate language
the second most widely spoken is
sicilian or
sichiliano it is spoken by around 4.7
million people
primarily in sicily and in parts of
calabria it is also an italo-dalmatian
language
like neapolitan sicilian has been
influenced by foreign languages like
greek
arabic spanish catalan and french
sicilian is sometimes said to be the
oldest romance language
meaning it was the earliest language to
split off from vulgar latin
but not everyone accepts this idea this
is not one of the recognized minority
languages either
another is venetian or veneto which is
spoken by around 3.9 million people
in the veneto region as well as in
neighboring trentino alto adige
and friuli venezia julia venetian was a
language of prestige in the time of the
venetian republic
and venetian was an important part of
the mediterranean lingua franca
also known as sabir a regional pidgin
language spoken between the 11th and
19th centuries
this is also not one of the recognized
minority languages
next is lombard or lombarda which is
spoken by 3.6 million people
mainly in the lombard region and parts
of neighboring regions
it is part of the gallo italic romance
branch along with ligurian and
piedmontes
piedmontes or pimontes is spoken by
around 1.6 million people
mainly in the piedmont region of
northwestern italy nigurian
or ligure is spoken by around 500 000
people in the liguria region
another gala italic language is emilian
romagnol
this language consists of two closely
related dialect groups
emilian and romanol it is spoken by
around 1.73 million people
mainly in the region of emilia romagna
this is
not a recognized minority language
next is sardinian or suzarudu it is
spoken by around 1 million people
mainly on the island of sardinia
sardinian is not part of the
italo-dalmatian branch but forms a
separate sardinian branch of romance
languages
so it's less intelligible for speakers
of italian than neapolitan or sicilian
sardinian is a recognized minority
language
next is friulian or furlan which is
spoken in the northeastern region of
friuli by around six hundred thousand
native speakers
it is a rito romance language that is
related to another language in northeast
italy
ladin as well as the romance language
spoken in switzerland
friulian is a recognized minority
language ladin
is also a recognized minority language
and is spoken by around 50 000 people
there are also the central italian
dialects or the aletti mediani
they are spoken in lazio umbria
the southern part of tuscany and part of
abruzzo these dialects are closely
related with each other and with tuscan
and are all part of the italo-dalmatian
branch these are thought of as italian
dialects rather than separate languages
even though they didn't develop from
tuscan but developed as sister dialects
to tusken there are around 3 million
speakers of these dialects
keep in mind that the number of speakers
for these regional languages might be
misleading because virtually everybody
is also fluent in standard italian
and their use of the regional languages
might be limited to certain situations
for example in communicating with their
elderly relatives
in smaller numbers there are also the
languages spoken in neighboring
countries either as regional or national
languages
german there are about 293 000 speakers
in northern areas of italy adjacent to
germany austria and switzerland
franco provencal has around 90 000
speakers
in the north near france mostly in
piedmont albanian
has around 80 000 speakers slovene has
around 70 000 speakers
near the border with slovenia oxyton has
around 40 000 speakers in piedmont and
liguria
catalan is spoken by around 20 000
people in the city of
algero on sardinia which began as a
catalan settlement
keeping in mind that the regional
romance languages are generally
considered dialects in italy i thought
it would be fun to
have a look at some of them and see how
similar or different they are let's look
at standard italian neapolitan sardinian
and friulian
vodka this means i would like something
to read
word for word it's would like first
person singular
something to read and a neapolitan
here the words all correspond and if
you're looking for it you can see the
connection between the words
but the words are also different enough
to make comprehension difficult
neapolitan words are often shorter than
the italian equivalent with final vowels
or
final syllables reduced in italian
there's vorae
this becomes vules in neapolitan i've
also seen this spelled with an e
at the end neapolitan spelling is not
standardized
italian qualicosa in neapolitan
the italian preposition da meaning from
or by
but also used before an infinitive like
this becomes a
in neapolitan the word for read is
similar except the final vowel sound
after r
is more like a schwa in neapolitan more
like an uh
sound unstressed vowels often sound like
schwa in neapolitan
and these reduced vowels are sometimes
not written in sardinia
unlike in italian and neapolitan in
which the personal pronoun eo was
dropped
here it's included and in sardinian it's
ia but i believe this can also be
dropped in sardinian
boli is the conditional form of the verb
which comes from the same root as the
italian and neapolitan ones
but it takes on a different form in
sardinia here
qualcosa is represented by two words
kankwakoza
i believe kankwa means some on its own
here the preposition is slightly
different
and then we have the verb meaning to
read which is obviously related to the
others but the infinitive is formed
differently
and in freon
here we see the personal pronoun e in
freolion this can't be dropped the verb
here
clearly comes from the same root as the
others but this one takes on quite a
different form
and as a learner of italian i might
mistake this for the italian word
volare which means to fly the word for
something
is alk i don't actually know the root of
this word but the way i'll remember it
is that it sounds like the middle of
kwalkoza cool now i'll never forget this
word
here notice the slightly different
preposition and notice the infinitive of
the verb meaning to read
this looks quite different from the
italian word but it looks rather similar
to the french word
liar or spanish so far you can probably
notice a lot of similarity when you look
at the sentences but there's also enough
difference to make these mutually
unintelligible to a large extent
when they're spoken mianodeto
verso leondici this sentence means they
told me that we will arrive around 11
o'clock
word for word it to me they have said
that
we will arrive around the eleven
in neapolitan manor
here we see that the object pronoun m
contracts with the verb
notice again that in neapolitan the
final vowel becomes reduced to a schwa
sound the main verb here is the
equivalent of
deto in italian d sounds in italian
often correspond to r
sounds in neapolitan the word k is
pronounced k
when unstressed and contracts with the
following verb
because of its initial vowel sound the
italian word arivaremo
is arivam in neapolitan pe is the
equivalent of
per in italian meaning for
becomes once again notice all those
reduced sounds
in sardinia
here we can see that similar to the
other languages in sardinian the past
can be expressed by using the auxiliary
verb meaning to have
even though it looks quite different the
un sound is a hint
the main verb however is different i'll
speculate that this verb now
is related to the latin verb narat
meaning t'tel
or narrate though i'm not sure k in
italian
is ka the future tense is formed
differently in sardinia with an
auxiliary verb
here instead of veraso we see akantade
which is similar to the italian
preposition akantoa
which means beside here we have a
different definite article
and undici becomes undigi in friulian
amiendita que rivarinto in friulian it
seems that rather than use a specific
indirect object pronoun
the preposition a is used with the
object pronoun
like to me here andite
is the past tense formed the same way as
in italian and neapolitan but with
different forms
here we have the subject pronoun which
is not necessary in the other languages
and here we have the verb for arrive but
you might not have immediately
recognized it because it begins with a
single
r rather than an a and a double r tor
is the preposition meaning around and
undis
this sentence means i have two brothers
and three sisters
word for word it's have first person
singular present tense
two brothers and three sisters in
neapolitan
in the italian sentence notice that the
verb for half is
o a form of the verb avere but in the
neapolitan sentence
it's teng this is similar to the word
used in spanish
in italian there's a word like this
tenere which would be tengo
in the first person singular but that
means to hold like in your hand
not to have in the general sense here
the word for two is slightly different
here the word for brothers is fratta
rather than fratelli and the word for
sisters is also shortened so
rather than sorely and notice that the
reduction of the endings make the gender
of nouns somewhat unclear
in this case of course we know because
of their meaning but with other nouns
the gender might be less clear
in sardinia
here the verb tenju is similar to the
neapolitan one
tenga two is deus rather than due
and three is tres rather than trey both
the verb
and the numbers remind me of spanish
here next
fraris and soris mean brother and sister
respectively
and notice that they form the plural by
adding an s this is how it's done in
many romance languages
but not in standard italian in which the
final vowel of the word indicates number
infrijulian
again we see that the pronoun can't be
dropped in freulean
here we see the verb to have which is a
cognate with the verb in the italian
sentence
unlike the ones in the neapolitan and
sardinian sentences
it's pronounced i but you can see a
connection with the french word a
tu is dos like in spanish the word for
brother is basically the same as the
sardinian word
and the plural is formed by adding s the
word for sister
sor is like the french word sur
as you can see from these examples
there's a lot of linguistic diversity in
italy with regional languages and their
local dialects
having their own colorful features that
reflect the history and the traditions
of their speakers
many of these languages and dialects are
endangered and risk being completely
replaced by standard italian in the
coming generations
there are some efforts to preserve these
languages but will they succeed
and that brings me to the question of
the day for people who speak both
italian and another language of italy
how often do you use your traditional
local language
and in what situations and for learners
of italian
has the influence of these traditional
languages and dialects ever affected
your communication with native speakers
let us know in the comments down below
be sure to follow langfocus on facebook
twitter and
instagram and once again thank you to
all of my wonderful patreon supporters
especially these ones right here on the
screen
for their monthly pledges thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you